there are gay lesbian and transgender
children
in Democratic Republican and independent
families some who fear for their lives
so with every Administration um the day
following in the inauguration is a
prayer sermon um right near um near the
White House it's in the Washington uh
Cathedral and presiding over this was um
Bishop buddy and she would
uh if it were the way it was supposed to
be she would you know put a blessing on
the president and his administration for
the years to come and that you know God
would lead throughout this
Administration instead here's what she
took advantage of
doing in the name of our God I ask
you to have mercy upon the people in our
country who are scared now there are gay
lesbian and transgender children
in Democratic Republican and independent
families some who fear for their lives
now Trump doesn't look very happy no so
he I'm sure he's thinking like where's
this where's this coming from but the
day prior in the day of the inauguration
he he sat and he signed a whole bunch of
executive orders one of the executive
orders um which I think fell under the
idea
of his um telling people in general I
just wanted an Administration that um
parallels with common sense so this
wasn't a a political view it wasn't a
religious view but it was what it was a
common sense View and he says so you
know he's writing an executive order
that from this point on WE the federal
government will recognize two genders
male and female MH well obviously from
what she said she's listening to LGBT
activists and I'm like wait a minute
aren't you
representing the word of God well it's
interesting that she started out the
conversation with that like in the name
of our God so kind of putting putting
her on the same playing field they she
knows that that people are are are kind
of ascribing religious ideas to Trump
and you know he's he's got the Christian
angle going with Trump supporters and so
she's trying to say like you know we're
on the same side and this is what in you
know we she believes God is should do I
watched everybody I rewatched this clip
many times the I think the the most
reaction I saw was from JD Vance who
turned and looked at his wife like are
you serious what and then the others I'm
sure they're trained well enough to know
don't react the med is just going to
jump all over it MH um and um Melania
you know she she stayed stoic um Trump I
could see that he was thinking he looked
annoyed so actually here's his reaction
to um the
service service what did you think of
the service what did you think did you
like it did you find it exciting not too
exciting was
it I didn't think it was a good service
now thank you very much thank you press
thank you PR much they can do much
better it was interesting as I begin to
see the reaction unfold on Facebook that
there were more people protecting the
bishop than there were what Trump's
reaction was to all of this like what
what were they kind of saying like um
you know I'm glad you brought that up
right there yeah yeah we should be you
know protecting LGBT people and their
rights um and and so I'm and as they
keep reading in these comments um about
the Protectors of the LGBT people and
Christians because most of my Facebook
friends identify as Christian and I'm
thinking wow you know here's the lady
who's supposed to be be a representative
of Christ if she had said something like
um I look forward to um working with you
or making advocacy for LGBT people that
they would come into a closer
relationship with Jesus Christ and see
what he truly has planned for them right
or or there or in respect to the um
executive order that you w wrote I also
agree because the Bible does say he
created them male and female Let's help
these people who have maybe been lost in
their feelings and their emotions come
to a point that they can see God's ways
as opposed to the counterfeit of
God so you you have a little bit of
experience um talk a little bit about
like you yeah so most of most of the
viewing a or a lot of the viewing
audience here probably knows a bit about
my testimony I led in the LGBT world for
40 years um I grew up Christian and at
18 I left the church um because I was
consumed with my feelings and they
didn't know exactly what God was asking
of me I think that's still the problem
today for many people dealing with this
issue so you hear about gay Christians
or LGBT Christians but what what comes
first in that you know the identifier
and so it's not about Christ it's about
self MH and and so God calls for us if
we read throughout scripture he calls
for us to deny ourselves and to live for
him and to agree with him to walk in
humility and meekness and find our true
identity which is going to be in living
in agreement with Jesus Christ so I have
concerns for clergy and church members
or even
family who have catered to the lgbti
atients almost as though they don't have
anything to share so I might as well
just give you your whatever right you
want to identify this way because
there's nothing I can do about it you
know um on one of the projects that
we've worked on um there was something
that was said um in one of the
interviewers that that said you know if
if if you have like this is just
absolute unconditional acceptance of
everything um that's really not a
representation that they that you
actually care about those people if if
you actually thought uh you know that
your salvation or something was in
danger yeah it's it's a merciful and
kind thing to say you know hey consider
this of course the way that you say it
is going to make a big difference you
know I don't think that we should be um
bullying people or slandering them or
whatever but but healthy discussion on
like hey um I I see that there's you
know the Bible saying this about what we
we should live and you know let's talk
about these issues um that's a healthy
way to deal with it and I think it also
shows that you actually care about
people so I've been in the the
um XK Ministry for lack of a better term
for 15 years and when I came back to
Christ I had to ask how did we get into
this mess and I wonder how many people
really give that consideration even
Christians because if we go back to what
occurred in in heaven the war in heaven
and the contention that um Lucifer
wanted to be higher than God and then he
couldn't be and so he wanted to um to
promote dissent amongst the angels in
heaven and told them that they should
follow the dictates of their own will so
we immediately we see a rising up of
self we see it happen again in the
Garden of Eden and with the angels that
are cast out of heaven and Lucifer being
cast out and his anger and being
literally mortified that the fact that
he can't be who he desires to be the
Temptation is that he wants to tempt you
and I to be who we want to be instead of
who God would like us to be and we've
we've lost sight of the of the Gospel of
Jesus Christ and being able to tell LGBT
people what it is that God has to offer
them
why would you deny yourself for Jesus
Christ MH I believe fully that we need
to walk the journey with LGBT plus
people but they should not if we're
going to identify as Christians there
they're not the ones that should be
calling the shots but they should we
should be drawing them into a study of
scripture into developing an intimacy
with Jesus Christ and figuring out that
Satan is wanting to bring about a
counterfeit on everything on family on
gender on marriage it's all over the
place he says he's got something better
and to
us feeling wise you know people are
following their feelings because it
feels good even if it's for a few
minutes yeah and that the feelings
become their truth and we have the whole
um the last few years where people have
said go with your gut go with your truth
yeah you know these stories are
literally a golden thread through many
of the stories in the Old Testament um
even in the New Testament but I'm I'm
thinking of Adam and Eve's first kids
you know you got Cain and Abel right
Cain was not trying to worship Satan
when he's you know put his put his fruit
on the Altar and didn't put the lamb
right he's not he's not not um trying to
worship a false deity he's just trying
to do it in his own way God says do this
he goes I'm not going to do that I'm
going to do this is God so you can see
an example of when we live outside of
the of of the way that God wants and and
bringing up an interesting point too
because um the war really isn't just
like you know straight versus LGBT
people if if if you can be honest
straight people deal with sin all the
time what you can't do though is you
can't just say well we're not going to
call this sin anymore and I'm just going
to like you know I'm going to go over
here and do it and and I don't want you
to say anything about that right um that
that would be a silly thing to do like
if I you know adultery on your on your
marriage or something like that you know
you're not going to just like condone
that so a Facebook friend of mine you
know posted a picture of a of Bishop
buddy and and said you know you know we
needed you know they applauded her and
that we need to Pro protect the LGBT
plus people so my my thought was how are
you protecting them if you go along with
the LGBT
ideations that's going deeper into the
LIE of the enemy why aren't we reaching
out with love with compassion but still
upholding God's true ways I mean we we
can all study together and I think we
should as as we work with the LGBT plus
community and sons and daughters and all
that we should expose to them that it is
God himself that is the definition of
love and today what we're dealing with
is a r definition of love that is
changing Church
culture yeah culture is kind of driving
the narrative
with with a lot of these things and um
you know rather than going back and
saying you know like what does God say
about this what is what is he want us to
to to experience life like see in
essence it is all about
God and not so much about self he
desires the very best for us but in his
ways that have been counterfeited um and
abused across time and here we are at
the end of time and our ministry should
be you know even bigger than ever to
reach out to those who are confused to
help them recognize that God has a plan
and a purpose for you and that something
probably meddled with or God in the way
um stat old statistics showed that 82%
of those identifying as
LGBT suffered from some kind of physical
or sexual abuse and so you can see
clearly that that um if you have that
attack attachment to hurt or harm you
don't want to be that person but if you
understand the cause and the deception
that came from the
enemy that in itself would begin to
motivate you from uhuh I'm not going to
believe you you're a liar I'm going to
live for Christ because not everyone of
the opposite sex is going to treat me
like trash you know that's just one of
the scenarios I there's lots of things
that cause um LGBT ideations you know
not bonding with a parent or maybe only
having a single parent or being I
there's so many different things not not
feeling like you're man enough when you
are a man and maybe how you were
belittled or teased or harassed on the
playground at school all these kinds of
things you have to remember those things
we can't blame God for those things we
should be blaming the enemy for those
things because God really wants his
design to play out and it really takes
our agreement with him and seeing his
ways and going I love your ways even
though even though that hasn't been my
experience I want to attain to that I
want that in the new world that you
offer me I want to be who you desire me
to be otherwise I'm not safe for heaven
or would I be happy being in heaven so
you know she mentions um children in
this article right here or in this um
speech that she had um what do you think
about that I mean are there really
children that are being bullied and
fearful for their life going to school I
mean what would you say to that I think
that the it really concerned me because
now you're talking about parents with
children that are identifying as LGBT
and I think about myself I didn't even
begin to identify as an LGBT even though
I had those feelings until I was an
adult like 18 plus and so when you
mentioned the protecting of of children
who now fear for their lives I'm like
why would they be fearing for their
lives because the president has gone
with a biological scientific uh
conclusion of two genders and so it puts
into question um the parents in my mind
particularly if they're Christian
parents and she was speaking from a
Christian Pulpit what are you teaching
your children why are they identifying
as LGBT instead of a a child of God or
um uh a believer you know in Jesus
Christ that from from the way she was
speaking it would make me think that
even in her own uh denomination or in
her spiritual teachings she doesn't see
any problem with the idea of being LGBT
but I can't find a foundation for that
in scripture it's a good point good
point you know the scripture does talk
somewhat about the issues of male female
um but you don't see it encouraging or
language that would seem to encourage
that well and we only need to go to and
it's often skipped over now 1
Corinthians 69- 11 who tells you these
people that you're identifying LGBT plus
it says they won't be in heaven and
verse 11 then turn arounds and says but
such were that some of you so change has
taken place and then we'd have to have a
discussion and we have had some
discussion about what is change so most
people today believe in the LGBT world
and their parents and friends think that
change means becoming heterosexual right
changing completely like how you feel
about that and everything that which
isn't always the case but it's a poent
it's a possibility for somebody I would
say probably 90% plus who transition out
of homosexuality don't become Stark
raving heterosexuals but they do come to
a point where they believe in God's ways
over the ways of the world or over the
way the deceptions of the enemy and
they're willing to live a life yes even
in uh celibacy for Christ because he
says you can become a new creation in
him those are some good points Wayne um
so um I thank you for coming on and
sharing with us and uh we hope that you
know people people treat anyone no
matter what what race no matter what
religion no matter with with dignity and
respect and love but at the same time I
think we need to have some some some
conversations especially
surrounding around
Christianity um and how are we to relate
to the Bible when when we see these
truths in the Bible yeah absolutely we
need we need to remember that we are
God's ambassadors and and root and
celebrate and draw people to his ways
instead of um moving in the direction of
the enemy
[Music]
oh